Transcriber: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
مرحبا. سأطلب من كل شخص أن  يقرأ هذا
النص خلال عشر ثوان.
حسنا. من يتذكر اسم الجامعة يقوم برفع يده.
الذي يتذكر اسم المدينة الموجودة
فيها الجامعة يرفع يده.
الذي يتذكر ما اسم المادتين الموجوديتن
بالليمون فليرفع يده.
أنا أحمد إسبير أتيت لأتحدث عن مهارة
تساعدنا  لنقرأ مثل النصوص بمعلوماة ضخمة،
وبتركيز غال جدا وبسرعة عالية
خلال وقت قصير.
دعونا نتحدث عن أرقام. هل تعلمون أن
هولز ستيفن بارك وصل ل25 ألف كلمة بالدقيقة،
ودخل موسوعة غينيس؟
تعرفه أنه آن جونز سيدة بريطانية عمرها
63 سنة، وصلت ل4200 كلمة بالدقيقة،
بحسب ديلي ميل البريطانية؟
وأن سي إي آدم وصل ل3850 كلمة بالدقيقة.
بالولايات المتحدة الأميركية.
وأن جيلك نارسن وصل ل3050
كلمة بالدقيقة بالنرويج،
وأن كريس فان أيمن وصل ل2520 كلمة
بالدقيقة في هولندا.
هذه الإحصائيات خارجية، لكن هل لدينا
مثلها في سوريا؟ من خلال عملي بهذا المجال،
قمنا بتدريب مجموعات بأعمار مختلفة،
بين15 و23 سنة، واستطعنا أن نحقق
أرقاما جيدة. هذه فتاة عمرها 19 سنة
وصلت 1056 كلمة بالدقيقة،
بنسبه تركيز 75 بالمئة.
شاب عمره 16سنة بالمركز الوطني
للمتميزين وصل ل600 كلمة بالدقيقة
هو رقم عادي جدا  لكنه مميز،
عندما  نعرف أن نسبة
الإجابات الصحيحة كانت مئة بالمئة.
لا يوجد إجابة خاطئة.
كيف استطاعوا تحقيق هكذا أرقام؟ بكل بلد
يتم القيام بتدريبات على هذه المهارة،
ويتم اختبارهذه المهارة على نصوص مع أسئلة
خاصة بها، وهكذا يتم قياس نسبة التركيز.
كل هؤلاء الأشخاص تدربوا على مهارة سأتكلم
عنها اليوم و هي القراءة السريعة.
ما هو تعريف القراءة السريعة؟ هي
بحسب دراسة قام بها ميهاو من جامعة كوريا،
وباول من جامعة فيكتوريا،
أنها هي عبارة عن مجموعة من الأساليب
تهدف لزيادة معدلات
سرعة القراءة مع زيادة التركيز.
حسنا.حتى نقوم بالقراءة السريعة،
يجب أن يكون هناك طرق. رحبوا بصديقنا
سونك، الذي سوف يساعدنا قليلا بأن نطبق
طرق القراءة السريعة.
أول طريقة هي القراءة المتكررة،
سوف يقراء سونك قراءة متكررة
على نصوص أو فقرات،
هذه الفقرات، سيأخذها لمحة أولية
بشكل متكرر بحركات سريعة.
يريد أن يحاول أن يتذكر ما فهم من النص،
ويحاول أن يركز على الأرقام،
وأن يركز على الأسماء الغريبة.
حسنا.سنجرب معا أن نقرأ هذا النص،
كل واحد بطريقته بعدها
نرى كيف سيعمل سونيك عليها.
سنبدا .
من لاحظ أن هناك ثلاثة عشر؟
من لاحظ أن هناك ستة ملليمتر؟
من لاحظ بان هنالك تسعة عشر بالمئة؟
حسنا ، سنرى كيف يطبق سونك هذه الآلية.
سوف يقرأ سونك بهذه الطريقة.
بنفس اللحظة التي تخرج فيها على الشاشة،
هذه اسمها حركات سريعة،
يعني يريد أن يأخذها بشكل لمحة أولية.
الطريقة الثانية هي القراءة الشاملة.
سيطبقها سونيك على نصوص طويلة،
سيقوم بذلك بمستويات متقطعة ويجزءها،
سيحاول أن يربط المعلومات وينسقها، وأن يأخذ
نظرة عامة عن كل فقرة من النص الطويل،
ويحاول أن يربط بين هذه الأفكار العامة
لأنها هي سوف تشكل مفهوم النص ككل.
حسنا. دعونا نرى سويا كيف ممكن أن نطبقها
على هذا النص من أوله لأخره.
بحسبكم أنتم؟
حسنا. سونك سعمل بهذه الألية.
قلنا انها تعتمد على نصوص طويلة سيقدمها
لفقرات اول فقرة هكذا وثاني فقرة في هكذا .